als luca marin freude herzlich
willkommen heute hier endlich mal wieder
zu einer lange erwarteten und ersehnten
und jetzt endlich vorhandene neuen
episode whatsapp feld
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt noch nie was bei
solchen leuten ab geht allerdings machen
wir direkt weiter mit dem nächsten
umfeld und verschreibt hat eine person
willst du einen guten baustellen witz
hören
keine ahnung was und baustellen wird ist
aber die andere personen schreibt haus
um 15.30 sechs minuten später schickte
ein fragezeichen hinter her und eine
stunde später kommt da noch was ist
leider noch nicht fertig ich wollte mich
ja das alter ist 22 1 und die haben mich
in den supermarkt noch rein gelassen
aber die hatten kein toilettenpapier
mehr und auch kein zebra und deswegen
musste ich jetzt weihnacht servierten
firma ein arschloch kaufen ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ja ganz besonders die nicht
nur noch maiskolben oder so hatten junge
wenn ich ein euro bekommen würde für
jede person die sich über die popkomm
preisen beschwert dann könnte ich mir
auch mal eine tüte leisten
o
bestimmt warum es popcorn eigentlich so
unendlich teuer ich meine das sind
einfach nur maiskörner
die kosten in der produktion gar nix
wahrscheinlich die zahlst quasi für
verbrannte maiskörner 7 millionen euro
was kannst du das wifi reparieren papa
hat irgendwas am fernseher gemacht und
jetzt geht das internet nicht mehr okay
moment eine minute später erledigt du
bist ein schatz woran lag's stromkabel
war nicht eingesteckt
das
tatsächlich auf meinem arm sein duo lisa
ich habe einen neuen witz also wer wird
beim trocknen nass sagt handtücher
ich
hab da auch mittlerweile keine worte
das sind zwei krankheiten die man besser
nicht zur gleichen zeit haben sollte ein
plan alzheimer und durchfall
warum naja du rennst aber weiß nicht
wohin
wer hat euch verarscht
hallo sohnemann ich habe mal wieder ein
lacher für dich parat in welchen zu
passt nur ein mensch egal wie sehr man
sich anstrengt liebe grüße thomas um
eine nachricht kann nur von einem thomas
kommen er schreibt überhaupt in der
whatsapp nachricht liebe grüße thomas
zumal das das ist dann scheint der vater
von der person ich weiß auch wer du bist
in verantwortet der sohn daraufhin haha
da bin ich aber gespannt und thomas sagt
dann in den anzug
liebe grüße thomas
punkt um punkt
warum sind eltern
kennst du das motto von 2020 sag mal so
rollt yourself wird negativ giebel wegen
kuroda also soll das gericht nicht nur
ein klatschen sondern nur sollen sowie
nach so referaten unser halb
eingeschlafen wird dann haben die ersten
angefangen zu klopfen sie ja war super
jafry geredet
und die bilder war da kommt man auch
recht gut lesen und ihr habt auch gut
frei geredet hier schreibt jemand um 3
uhr 12 die nachricht mein nachbar hat
einfach gerade bei mir sturm geklingelt
um drei uhr nachts man dann am nächsten
morgen also am gleichen morgen
eigentlich aber bei mir ist es immer so
wenn ich noch nicht schlafen war aber es
ist schon nach zwölf ist für mich
trotzdem noch der alte tag und der neue
tag beginnt dann bin ich wieder auch
super smart etf ist der bescheuert jahre
alte aber zum glück war ich eh noch wach
warum warst du um drei uhr nachts noch
wach wtf ich habe auch schlagzeug geübt
papa ja wenn ich ein ladekabel in der
steckdose habe aber nicht am ladekabel
angeschlossen habe verbrauchen wir dann
trotzdem genau diese frage ich mir jetzt
kind auch gestellt alter ich habe
nämlich sogar als ich gegen wie noch
sogar 13 oder 14 oder ob ich trotzdem
noch immer alle ladekabel rausgestreckt
aus der steckdose
also nicht also rausgezogen aus der
steckdose gesteckt weil ich die ganze
zeit dachte ich verbrauche hier voll
vielen strom in meinem zimmer und so
weiter und so fort aber es ist ja das
ist eine kindheit sachen um sie wollte
ja schon immer den hund als haustier ja
und naja ich habe jetzt den mops besorgt
und trotz der kurzen leine der
eingedrückten nase den komischen auf und
in welchen markt ja und sylvie echt
geehrt hahahaha wer ist für dich bruder
niklas ich habe ein komplettes spielzeug
dem kinderheim gespendet was warum
damit ist er dort nicht langweilig mama
papa ihr behandelt mich echt wie einen
gott das freut uns aber zu hören warum
in kaarst miley wie am 8 doch solche
smileys auf jeden fall schreibt der sohn
und ihr glaubt nicht an mich wir stehen
mit dir
wir stehen ein einsteige zehn sekunden
für dich
[Musik]
nicht jetzt
nicht jetzt dass das passt gar nicht ein
drogentest war negativ dicker chillig ja
mega hat mein chef auch gefreut aber ich
muss jetzt mal ein ernstes wörtchen mit
meinem widerspruch
[Musik]
das ist so dumm was ist der unterschied
zwischen klatsche und klatsch keine
ahnung ein sturz aus dem ersten und
einer aus dem zehnten show
das
tut weh haha witzige szene heute im
krankenhaus hat sich ein mann gewogen
und sein bauch eingezogen und seine frau
meinte dann das bringt nichts bernd und
dann eher so aber nur so kann ich die
zahl lesen a ha ha ha ha ha
aha
die leute die solche langen hahahahaha
nachrichten schreiben die lachen
meistens gar nicht alt haben hat gerade
ein vogel aufs auto gepackt hahaha
der lacht eigentlich gar nicht und wer
schreibt der ha ha ha ha ha ha opfer und
dann antwortet der andere dem der vogel
aufs auto gepackt hat wieder ich gehe
jetzt nach hause und es hört auf meinem
balkon einfach nur damit der parasit wer
hier der boss ist das können eins zu
eins so von sandra köppen du baustopp
warum hast du das kinder werde
eigentlich so hoch gebaut so können wir
besser hören wenn das kind ihn aus dem
bettchen fest
hier schreibt ein schüler an einen
anderen schüler während des unterrichts
hast du die hausaufgaben gerade selbst
gemacht oder mit deinem vater zusammen
also anscheinend die hausaufgaben wie
vorgestellt oder so er antwortet dann
auf jeden fall nicht mit meinem vater
zusammen sagt hast du so schlau hh mein
dad hat die komplett alleine gemacht
hahaha
willst du den kürzesten witz aller
zeiten hören sagt an brennholz verleih
punkt punkt punkt wie kann man bei
whatsapp leute blockieren das würde ich
mich an
der gab wer klingelt denn jetzt bei mir
[Applaus]
voll vergessen dass ich mit drei breaks
bestellt habe ja ich hab halt hunger
und dann machen wir nur noch ein wort
weil wir heute meine lieben freunde und
zwar sind diese hier live und ist vor
einer woche gestoppt oder darf da muss
ich so an die ganze sache herangehen
laras hund ist vor einer woche gestorben
ich habe ihr dann genau den gleichen
hund noch mal gekauft und sie fand es
nicht gut
warum er jetzt hat sie zwei tote hunde
tommy ramm kompetente steinkohle